CBS News senior national security
analyst Fran Townsend was homeland
security and counterterrorism advisor
for president george w bush for and good
morning what are your sources telling
you about the sophistication of these
bombs so they described them as crude
and low ordnance that doesn't mean that
they someone wouldn't have been hurt or
maimed if they were opened but it tells
you something about the bomber right and
so I understand the all of the outsides
of all of the packages look the same
these manila envelopes to rose and flag
stamps all of the mailing envelopes done
you know all the addresses separately
done and stuck on and so all of these
provide real forensic evidence right you
look at your lick stamps you touch
envelopes all of that will help
investigators very quickly identify the
bomber I suspect what's the likelihood
that investigators know of this bomber
that he's on their radar so it's it's
interesting at least three of them right
the Obamas the Clintons and the Biden's
have all been former protectees of the
United States Secret Service who keep an
extensive database of those who tend to
threaten high-profile protect DS so you
can expect that they're going back
through to see if there's any common
links or suspects that they may have
already identified in the past as we can
went on the air just now we saw a lot of
pictures of an NYPD truck
then police car heading down the West
Side Highway is a concern now that there
are more packages out there there is
Gail eyes to be the that's right this
morning very frightening right
investigators there's an hand screening
at the US Postal Service that started
yesterday they do expect you may see
additional packages today they think all
of these packages were mailed between
the 16th and 18th of October and so it's
likely if once we get through today they
should have identified everything that's
in the systems you mentioned most of
them were mailed but it's also believed
that one of them may have been
hand-delivered so looking at couriers
been we know when New York City there
are cameras everywhere
that's right that's right I mean what I
heard from the the PD and the this is
being handled and coordinated out of the
FBI's counterterrorism division in
Washington that says something that it
sure does and that's because it's
multi-jurisdictional and they're still
trying to identify suspects they think
that it that may have been they actually
may all have been mailed but they're
looking at all the footage to see if
they can identify
seems like authorities have a lot to
work with do they they do I'm like what
friends so as I mentioned you know
stamps get licked envelopes get touched
mailing the mailing labels all had to be
done on either the same computer the
same typewriter right all of those are
forensic details then you get inside the
package and you've got the PVC pipe the
wires the powder all of that is a
signature right and you look for where
did he obtain them did they all come
from the same place what there's a
question in these cases whether this is
or isn't terrorism in terms of
definitionally what is it does that seem
like terrorism straight up to you
it sure does when you're looking to
inflict you know fear and terror for a
political means on a civilian population
had pretty much triggers the definition
when I spoke with the FBI director they
talked about containing the threat from
home grown terrorists that this may not
necessarily be in terms of the threats
now are people who actually live here
right the American citizens yeah there's
no indication it's interesting although
they're calling this terrorism there's
no indication that this isn't anything
with to do with an overseas threat
I think the operating assumption from
investigators that I've spoken to is it
is a homegrown threat there are now nine
reported bombs what does it tell you
that none of them have detonated you
know I don't I wouldn't I actually think
in some ways we ought to take comfort
from the fact that haven't detonated I
think the screening system is working I
think that it the interagency process to
identify these devices and the training
that people have gone through since the
years ago the Unabomber case I think
it's it says more about this screening
system and that people take it seriously
unfortunately no one's hurt but so many
in this country now on high alert yeah
and thank you so much